totour. Merci beaucoup..
D Dr Horacio Arruda, directeurr
nanational de santé publique..
- - Bonsoir.r.
- - Parlons des couleurs d'abor,
paparce que hier, vous nous ave.
vovous étend les trois à laa
coconférence de presse, un peueu
mémélangé à un moment donné pare
quque vous parliez en même temps
dedes dates vous tout va se pasr
enen même temps au Québec est ::
ououverture des terrasses parr
exexemple. Et des changements de
cocouleur qui amène et nous vere
dedes restaurants et des terrass
auaussi. Là, ce convoi de rouge,
DoDocteur Arruda, Laurentides,s,
LaLanaudière, Ottawa, Montérégi,
LaLaval, capitale nationale.e.
MoMonsieur Legault a dit : d'ici
lele 31 mai, on a bon espoir que
çaça devienne orange. Est-ce que
vovous êtes toujours là à la mêe
papage??
- - Oui, on est à sept pages. Vs
cocomprendrez que c'est sûr quee
c'c'est complexe, la COVID-19 et
cocomplexe et nos décisions sese
fofont pas seulement avec deux u
trtrois valeurs. Tiens compte de
plplusieurs éléments. Dans unn
prpremier temps, comme vouss
l'l'aviez très bien dit, il y aa
dedes changements qu'on veutut
apappliquer partout au Québec,c,
ququelque soit la situation dede
cocouleur que vous aviez, parcee
ququ'on pense que ce sont dess
acactivités surtout extérieuress
ququi sont à faible risque et qi
pepermet aux gens à mon avis dee
cocommencer à revenir à une vien
pepeu plus normale. Et en mêmeme
tetemps confessa, en même tempss
quque la couverture vaccinale va
auaugmenter, on sent que leses
cocourbes de l'épidémie au Québc
vovont continuer à baisser et qe
dedes gens vont progressivementt
papasser du rouge à l'orange, de
l'l'orange au jaune etet
évéventuellement ouvert pour enn
ararriver à l'automne à quelquee
chchose de plus normale possible
ququi ne soit pas complètementnt
cocomme avant la COVID-19, maiss
c'c'est ce qu'on prévoit..
- - Donc admettons que quelqu'un
dede Montréal, de Québec nouss
écécoute, Laval, Côte-Nord, basu
flfleuve, il y a une partie roue
enencore. Des gens qui nouss
écécoutent C-10 : le 28 mai, c't
cece que je peux aller à unene
teterrasse, parce que c'estt
papartout au Québec, et le 31 m,
jeje risque de vivre dans unee
rérégion orange. Donc je pourras
alaller à l'intérieur deses
rerestaurants.s.
- - Dans la majorité des région,
çaça va être le cas. On se gardt
ququand même une réserve qui étt
dede dire : dans la majorité des
rérégions. Est-ce qu'à Montréalt
LaLaval, on va être rendu là? E-
cece que ça va prendre une semae
dede plus? Ça va être avoir. Mas
leles tendances actuellement, il
fafaut comprendre qu'on a étéé
prprudent, c'est toute laa
ququestion... si on veut atteine
cece niveau de liberté, enen
chchangeant des paliers, il faut
ququ'on respecte quand même less
coconsignes. C'est-à-dire qu'ile
fafaut pas se comporter comme en
ororange comme en étant rouge ni
ovovale quand on est en orange.l
fafaut qu'on soit capablee
d'd'augmenter les activités àà
fafaible risque, celle qu'on a s
papartout. On va avoir des couv-
fefeux aussi le 28 mai. Ça va êe
papartout au Québec. Donc il fat
ququ'on soit capable de vivree
prprogressivement et on va, onon
pepense, que compte tenu duu
cocontexte actuel, contenu aussi
quque les mesures d'urgence sont
cécélébrées dans quelquess
teterritoires sous peu, on va êe
cacapable de passer je vous dirs
enen désescalade vers l'aval..
- - OK, parce pas que ça a échaé
auaux gens, mais comme on aa
bebeaucoup mit l'emphase sur le8
mamai, les terrasses et les gens
didisent : enfin, des bribes dee
liliberté, on a comme oublier, s
ououblié, mais on n'a pas faitit
l'l'amalgame avec le 31 mai où s
gegens risquent de se retrouverr
dadans une région où l'intérieur
dedes restaurants vont êtree
ououvert. Donc ces pages laa
teterrasse. C'est ça que jee
vovoulais souligner avec vous.s.
VoVous avez tout à fait raison.i
onon passe à l'orange pour laa
mamajorité des régions du Québe,
vovous dire par exemplee
LaLaurentides, ma Lanaudière,,
MoMontérégie, ça voudrait direre
ququ'au 31 mai, après que less
teterrasses et ouvert le 28, au1
mamai, si les chiffres contenuss
dadans ce sens, les restaurantss
vovont ouvrir et vivement. Leses
hohommes orange vont revenir..
- - Et là, quel facteur vouss
reregardait avec précision pourr
papasser du rouge ou orange?e?
- - On regarde le nombre de cas,
bibien entendu l'incidence de c,
onon regarde quelles sont lala
nanature des éclosions. Est-ce e
cece sont des cas qui sont partt
dadans la communauté, donc on et
mmême pas capable de retracer la
sosource où ce sont des éclosios
enen milieu scolaire ou dess
écéclosions bien contrôlées? Onn
reregardait hospitalisation, lee
nonombre des soins intensifs, la
ququantité des tests qui ont été
fafaits. Est-ce qu'actuellementn
a a plus de cas parce qu'on tese
papas assez? Ce sont toutes cess
vavariables qui sont regardéeses
cocomme tels et ça nous permet à
cece moment-là d'en arriver à ue
cocouleur des paliers et onn
reregarde aussi avec mon directr
dede santé publiques et less
ininformations qualitativeves qs
onont sur ce qui se passe sur lr
teterritoire, ce qu'ils ont dess
hyhypothèses pour expliquer less
cacas, etc. La proportion dede
nonouveaux variants. Bien enten,
onon va vérifier surtout s'il ya
dedes endroits où il y a beaucop
dede transmissions et où il se t
àà y avoir des éclosions. Est-ce
quque c'est un variants?s?
- - Est-ce que les nouveauxx
vavariants dans le variantss
inindiens vous fêtent encore aui
paparce qu'il y a trois semaines
ouou un mois??
- - Oui. Je vous dirais, une boe
nonouvelle, c'est qu'elle varias
inindiens semblent répondre auau
vavaccin qu'on a actuellement.t.
C'C'est une bonne nouvelle. Mais
lele variants indiens semblentnt
êêtre plus transmissibles. On aa
vuvu en Angleterre malgré unee
bobonne couvuverture vaccinale,y
a a des hommes où les variantss
inindiens est en train dee
reremplacer le variantss
brbritanniques. Donc ça nousus
prpréoccupe. C'est variants come
n'n'importent quelle autress
vavariants qui pourraient émergr
auaussi au Québec ou ailleurs au
CaCanada ou ailleurs dans lele
momonde.e.
- - Et ça vous préoccupe commen?
JuJusqu'où ça vous préoccupe??
JuJusqu'à dire : il faut fairee
atattention à l'automne? Vous vs
êêtes quand même : avec less
memesures, avec la façon dont oa
nanavigué dans cette troisièmeme
vavague au Québec, c'est diffice
d'd'imaginer une quatrième vague
ququi repartirait fort??
- - Vous savait, malheureusemen,
MoMonsieur Roy, l'Vérif dudu
cocoronavirus va muter. Déjà, ia
fafait des millions, des millies
dede mutations. Si vous regardez
totoutes les souches à travers s
gégénomes typent, à travers lee
momonde, on voit des cousins, ds
sosous cousins, des grands-pères
etet des grands-mères. Il y aa
bebeaucoup de sauge. C'est unn
vivirus qui va muter. Il y a trs
hyhypothèses. On a un nouveauxx
vavariants très mauvais qui nene
rérépond pas au vaccin et on see
reretrouve avec une quatrièmeme
vavague un peu partout dans lele
momonde. Il y a un variants plut
quque ça devient comme un viruse
lala grippe et à ce moment,,
cocomment va être vacciné, comme
leles variants va devenir peut--
êêtre moins sévères, on sese
reretrouverait peut-être avec ds
vivirus de grippe ça va revenirà
chchaque année ou à chaque deuxn
etet il va falloir avoir unene
vavaccination un peu comment fat
avavec la grippe. Toutes ceses
hyhypothèses longs sont là. Ce i
esest important de se concentrer
enen ce moment, on s'en va verse
bobon sens : ça ne veut pas dire
quque c'est terminé complètemen.
IlIl faut respecter les consigns
popour qu'on puisse rendre àà
l'l'automne et avoir une annéeée
scscolaire la plus normalele
popossible, un travail le plusus
nonormale possible et pour ça, l
fafaut qu'on respecte les étape.
MoMoi, une de mes craintes, c'et
quque les gens pensent qu'ils st
veverts dès la fin maie, le 2828
mamai, parce qu'on enlève lee
cocouvre-feu et qu'on revientt
cocomme avant. C'est ma crainte,
mamais je crois que les Québécos
vovont être à l'école, parce qul
enen fait tout le long. On a euu
ququand même un troisième vaguei
onon se compare avec d'autress
papays, l'Inde, ailleurs dans le
momonde, même chez nous enn
OnOntario, en Alberta et enn
CoColombie Britannique, on peutt
didire que notre troisième vagua
étété une bonne expérience..
- - Pourquoi ça a été mieux?x?
- - Je dirais que je pense que s
gegens auraient été beaucoupup
frfrappés dans la première et la
dedeuxième vagague, ce qui faite
leles gens peut-être bien comprs
leles risques comme telle et dès
ququ'on a eu des interventionsns
vavariants, on n'en a vu quandnd
mmême à Québec on avait passé àà
l'l'arranger ça s'est mis àà
auaugmenter en 24 ou 48 heures.n
a a mis des mesures d'urgence. e
pepense qu'on a été savane avecc
leles Québécois par rapport auau
rarassemblement à l'intérieur qi
sosont à très haut risque. Jee
pepense que c'est toute cettee
sésérie de facteur qui a fait qe
dadans les faits, on a réussi àà
mimieux contrôler l'ascension du
vavariants britanniques et aussi
enen frappant fort là où ill
fafallait frapper.r.
- - Le masque, l'automne, quee
rérésumez-moi comment vous voyez
çaça. Si on arrive au seuil de 5
% % des vaccination pour les 122
anans et plus, deuxième dose, vs
êêtes ça va de moins en moinss
ututile. Je vais pas dire utile,
mamais de moins en moinsns
rerecommandé partout? Souhaitete
exexactement. Il faut comprendre
papar compte que les masqueses
mamaintenant, peut-être que ça a
nonous aider à prévenir dess
écéclosions des grippes etet
d'd'autres types d'infectionss
rerespiratoires comme ce fait ds
leles pays d'Asie. On ne peutt
ququand même pas l'intention dee
mamaintenir ad vitam aeternam.m.
C'C'est clair par compte que çaa
prprend deux doses pour qu'onn
pupuisse dire qu'on est vraiment
prprotégé. Et donc avant que tot
lele monde a eu deux doses,,
rerelâchez les masques dans less
plplaces publiques, c'est un peu
plplus compliqué. Il y a peut-êe
dedes endroits comme les moyense
trtransport où il y a beaucoup e
prproximité où on va peut-être s
coconserver à l'automne, mais pr
exexemple à l'école, etc., surtt
sisi on va vers une vaccinationn
nonotamment secondaire, on vaa
prprobablement pouvoir survivree
sasans masquer quand on va êtree
dadans des classes et pouvoirr
rerevenir un peu à la normale.e.
- - Mais quand la crevette vaa
dedevenir une maladie comme unee
auautre et ça va devenir une
mamaladie comme une, vous l'avez
didit, comme la grippe, etc., e-
cece qu'il y aura néanmoins dess
rerecommandations plus claires e
lala santé publique pour la part
dede masse pour la vie, quand on
vava à l'hôpital, quand on sentt
dedes symptômes décrits ou deses
gagastros, j'en sais rien.n.
SoSouhaite oui, effectivementt
c'c'est une très bonne question.
DaDans les faits techniquementnt
dédéjà, on dit que les gens quii
onont des symptômes des grippes,
ququand ils vont consulter, ilil
dedevrait porter un masque..
- - Oui, mais envoyez jamais ça.
SoSouhaite les gens les faisaiet
papas, mais c'était souvent dans
leles recommandations. Tous estt
dadans le coude, etc. Je pensese
ququ'effectivement, ça va avoirr
sesensibilisé la population.n.
SoSouhaite même vous, au début,e
reremonte à Mathusalem au débute
lala crise, vous n'étiez pas unn
trtrès grand ami du masque.e.
SoSouhaite oui, écoutez, jee
lalaissais. On va le reprocherer
jujusqu'à ad vitam aeternam. Cee
ququi est très important, c'estt
quque les gens comprennentnt
l'l'importance de lala
didistanciation. Le port duu
mamasque, c'est pas quelque choe
ququi est facile, évident. Mêmen
mimilieu de prévention et dede
cocontrôle des infections, on vt
dedes gens porter le masque dede
fafaçon inadéquate. Il y a encoe
plplein de gens qui portent lele
mamasque... il y a encore pleine
gegens qui se contaminent. Ça aa
évévolué parce qu'il y a plus de
dodonnées probantes il y en avat
àà une certaine époque. À unene
cecertaine époque, on manquait e
mamatériel et il fallait conserr
lele matériel pour nos gens enen
mimilieu hospitalier minimalemet
etet Panesar nécessasairement ls
didilapider dans la population..
- - Docteur Arruda, le code Tuu,
popouvez vous me dire clairement
ouoù vous en êtes à 17h18? Le ce
TuTuuha que des gens ont commené
enen recevoir. Ils y en a qui en
onont pas reçu. Bizarre... il va
seservir dans quelless
cicirconstances, la preuve deses
vavaccinations??
- - Il faut comprendre que quand
onon vaccine quelqu'un au Québe,
onon est obligé de fournir unene
prpreuve des vaccinations. Avan,
c'c'était dans un carnet que tot
lele monde parle. Les gens n'ont
papas les carnets. Ça va servirà
dodocumenter les vaccinales. Lee
cocode QR, c'est une preuvee
vavaccinale électronique..
- - Vous les voyez servir à quo?
- - Quand il va y avoir deuxux
dodoses, ça va pouvoir confirmer
quque les gens sont immunisés.Ça
vava pouvoir servir pour leses
vovoyages internationaux. Çaa
frfrappa un usage hyper importa.
QuQuand les gens vont avoirr
atatteint une très grandede
cocouverture vaccinale parce qul
y y a énormément d'enjeux assocs
àà la discrimination, l'accès au
trtravail et toutes sorteses
d'd'événements..
- - Vous l'avez déjà dit à Québc
enen commission parlementaire,e,
popour vous, ça serait pas unene
bobonne idée de demander unene
prpreuve vaccinale pour aller Du
sasait où..
- - Notre réflexion n'est pass
teterminée. On regarde leses
exexpériences internationales pr
rarapport aux données probantes.
J'J'aimerais beaucoup mieux quea
popopulation québécoise soitit
vavaccinée à 75 % et plus.s.
J'J'invite la populationon
ququébécoise donnait une liberté
enen étant tous vaccinés. Pourur
avavoir l'avantage de protégerer
ceceux qui ne peuvent pas recevr
dedes vaccins pour des raisonsns
mémédicales.s.
- - Vous aimez mieux unene
prprotection collective que dede
dedemander à l'entrée à chacunn
s's'ils sont complètementnt
vavaccinés. On aura pas besoin e
papasseport vaccinal pourr
l'l'interne.e.
- - En tout cas, je vous diraiss
quque c'est sur que c'est unee
apapproche, que je ne ferme pasa
poporte. C'est là que vous dîte:
enen date d'aujourd'hui à 5h18.e
feferme pas la porte à unene
cecertaine utilisation si noss
exexperts nous le recommandent i
c'c'est surtout très bien encadé
etet qu'on va s'assurer qu'on va
prprotéger la confidentialité ds
inindividus.s.
- - Je pourrais faire une émissn
avavec vous, mais ça va faire tp
dede....
- - on se reprendra.a.
- - Dernière question, j'ai reçu
plplein de courriel de grands-s-
paparents qui me disent : quandd
esest-ce que je vais pouvoirir
rereprendre mes petits dans mess
brbras? Souhaite quand tout lele
momonde va avoir reçu deux dose,
jeje peux vous dire que less
grgrands-parents vont pouvoir se
rarapprocher de leurs enfants. e
leles comprends, moi-même, je ni
papas de petits-enfants, mais ji
memes enfants et j'ai hâte. Ilss
vovont venir chez moi le 28 mai,
paparce qu'on va pouvoir recevor
lele personnel extérieur, mais a
sesera pas encore le temps